on the fifth day of the Norway chess
tournament the players got to see more
of the beautiful countryside the fourth
round was played in the hood Stein Abbey
on the island of monster oil the
monastery was built in the 13th century
when the king of norway was called
Magnus the sixth and it should be added
that the monastery was restored in the
20th century by an architect named
Fisher
the players seem to enjoy the change of
surroundings and delivered another great
round of fighting chess it was a bad day
for the local fans though Carlson lost
his third game and hammer also went down
it was fishy on on to played an
excellent game today it's nice it's
freezing it's really freezing I'm I mean
in the hall well I simply didn't know
that this is the place we were coming to
for some reason there's a huge castle on
the other bank of the fjord near hotel
and I thought that looks like a
monastery so I thought that must be it I
saw a tweet by John whose big buzz what
what it was in reality yeah it was a
mental it's a mental hospital apparently
but anyway you gotta hand it to these
guys even the mental hospitals look
enormous but I I simply should have
brought a sweater or something it's it's
insane
but okay if you win you forget about it
for a while so the gameís was pretty
good
to what extent were you feeling that
during the game that you were renewing
well today I I had the feeling during
the whole game that I could be doing
well but I could eat just as equally not
be doing well I mean the position was
difficult at least in practical terms it
seemed to me that black has many many
resources so I was finding it hard to
nail it
but after 93 Bishop d3 cd3 queen d1 I
started to feel very optimistic because
suddenly it's beautiful my other row
comes to f2 and I've got a massive
attack going and something will turn up
so there I started to feel good did you
consider the ending winning when you
decided to go for it I thought it I
would have been very surprised if it
turned out to be not winning but in fact
I felt that I I'd probably miss
something bigger if that isn't the case
then I'm very happy that I found this
ending but for me the ending was the
last resort because I thought how does
he escape again and I was quite furious
with myself and then I saw Bishop g7
Knight f5 and this Knight d7 and then I
was very happy because at least this I
thought and it's perfect cos Bishop g7
gets me to the time control as well so I
was relieved at this point